[Music]
here in this video we will take a look
at the mix and confusing timeline of the
predators on earth and of world
including the events from comics the avp
crossover that many of you don't like
but you know let's keep it inclusive as
well as that of the new prey movie which
threw the timeline into a separate
branch of reality let's say so let's
start with the ancient timeline and then
go on eventually to the modern era and
the future
around 5 billion years ago yautja prime
was formed which is one of the several
planets to orbit a multiple star system
many light years away and with a cluster
of delhi asteroids and moons orbiting it
4.5 billion years ago the earth is
formed around a young star called sol
later getting a moon for itself
272 million years ago therapists evolved
which are believed to be ancient
ancestors steal their predators which is
theorized in the comics the predator
home world since they had both mammalian
and reptile characteristics much like
the modern yautja
unspecified millions of years ago
proto predators evolved on yautja prime
which later took form as a single basal
species of predators on the planet and
then later branched off into several
subspecies like the hunters the feral
the super predators etc
3000 bc yautja established temple styles
compounds on earth over some of which
were hunting and training grounds for
their youthful warriors it is here that
the young bloods achieved their blooding
ceremony after killing a xenomorph
1700 to 1709 the shogun tokugawa tunia
yoshi and his forces faced sudden attack
from a group of yautja ending in a final
duel between one yautja and the blind
swordsman chosen by the shinto monks
1718 ce in the islands surrounding papua
new guinea during the golden age of
piracy a captain called rafael adelini
chants an encounter with a predator and
in the ensuing mutiny and battle he
gifted the yautja with a flintoff pistol
bearing his own name
1719 ce one individual a young native
american comanche warrior named naru is
recorded to have taken a warrior's role
against the pharaoh yautja and defeated
it in combat by learning about its
strengths and weaknesses and laying a
trap for the predator
how to catch a predator she received the
same raphael adelini flintoff but from a
french first skin hunter slash traitor
1863 and 1881 ce a group of union and
confederate soldiers team up to fight a
yautja drawn by the american civil war
in india a yautja hunts villagers and
british troops including a young edward
sons
in bengal india giving rise to the local
legend of a rakshasa
or a hindu demon stalking the area the
year 1904 the razorback wailing
station disaster whereby a group of
whalers released a predator from a metal
port and released a bunch of xenomorphs
as well from an alleged temple the
predator managed to kill both the
whalers and xenos
1904 to 1986
there was a whole lot of predator
sightings encounters and hunts all over
the world from chicago in the united
states to nicaragua from new jersey to
japan and even russia but all news are
kept under type raps
1987 the god of mailer incident whereby
a cia operative hires a bunch of green
beret all
also known as mercenaries under the
leadership of dutch for a guerrilla
attack and to save hostages but this
turned out to be a battle against a
russian and central american agency's
intelligence agencies but then it became
a battle for survival against a jungle
hunter predator which then resulted in
only dutch and a woman called gonsalves
to make it out alive from there get down
get down get to the chopper
the year 1997 the los angeles heat wave
incident in that year los angeles
endeared a cartel street war as two
competing gangs fought for turf this
became an ideal hunting ground for the
city hunter predator which resulted in a
bloodbath with officer harrington
managing to kill the predator in the end
and also receiving a
adelini flint up pistol as a souvenir
from a predator
2004
at the avp alien versus predator
incident a weyland gathered a small crew
of experts from a variety of fields to
investigate the bovet island temple
location this resulted in three
predators being sent off to cut off an a
cinema of infestation ending in the
death of all three predators all humans
and the zenos except for a woman and the
remaining predators that came afterwards
the same year 2004 the body of the slain
predator from avp erupted to a new life
form called a hybrid predalien resulting
in their spaceship crash in colorado
united states this was the avp requiem
incident resulting in a nuclear bombing
of a u.s city to get rid of all alien
life and xeno infestation
the early 21st century the yavja civil
war occurs between two factions from the
same planet the hunters and the bad
blood of the berserkers are also known
as the super predators
well not much is known about this civil
war but
when you find out later that the hunters
survive it means that they won
2010 a group of humans are kidnapped and
transported to a game-preserved planet
where they are hunted and forced to
become prey for a group of super
predators other aliens like the
river ghost was also a part of the game
this is where the predator civil war was
confirmed
2018 two predators one of fugitive and
the other and ultimate upgrade predator
arrive on earth both looking for a
special weapon that the fugitive
predator planned to give to humans to
defend the world against a planned
invasion of the earth by their species
2020 the group called the other worldly
life form program
remains the standard in investigating
yavja incidents on earth
and has started to expand operations
globally in order to learn and track
down yaoja and alien incidents on the
planet
2040 the organization known as spearhead
is formed to combat yaoja with
state-of-the-art technology and at the
same time subutai an immortal japanese
samurai decides on a final showdown with
the predators
217 after nearly a hundred years without
recorded incident or sighting of the
predators
they the alger attacked a thousand
strong human colony on the planet called
midnight
2219
ce a predator called ahab became
involved in a situation with humans
eldon and xenomorphs on board a ship
called the garyon later ahab
finds tracks and you know battles an
engineer and eventually manages to
secure a win even though losing the
function of his arm
2593 ce a predator drone ship places
alien eggs onto the planet alpha
centauri 3 which hatch and produce a
fine crop of alien prey the human
population is eradicated in the process
and the predators get a lot of fun
killing the xenos
2692 ce
the rage a ban of outcasts humans with a
vast amount of xenomorphs as shock
troops plan to wipe out humanity in
revenge for them being exiled
the danger is then thwarted by a group
of people and also
finding help from the predators the
yavja
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam